guys it's Monday and I just want to say
that it's really important to love
yourself [ __ ] and that Mehcad bro
cab got photo right with a mountain lion
because no cat gonna fight with a cat
would be the way to go there with a cat
cat got in final encounter large cat cuz
it ripped a large halls in her teens now
cat your rebuttal could be Brian 51 and
doesn't know if I like him I like him
not as a set of legs on this she I was
gonna say when you have legs like that
you're allowed to do that yeah I've got
powerlifting thighs don't squat it all
the way in the world before I got
injured 240 is that right that's
impressive
that's how life's as much as Brian that
that is that is definitely right with me
here's some big size like do not knock
about saying lay in a good way like an
on their muscular their athletic like
CrossFit thighs which is I appreciate
very much yeah and like a non-creepy
boss kinda way be careful to be cool if
you're if you have to Jim oh God how's
it Julie no no I liked him was it green
in the young men he waits on me in the
morning if I gotta for breakfast has
beautiful eyes and I was like I was like
you have you and I said you look great I
was gonna say you beautifies I know I
gets Miss America you look great that's
a really nice color on you that's all I
could do
I had to keep it very copacetic and then
I said I want to drink deeply of your
lips no but you know you gotta just be
Carrie
I don't know I don't know how it's gonna
be received I see are you gonna go back
to Julian tomorrow Mike you know I can I
get a can I get the egg sandwiches a
dicksuck excuse me I'm sorry um did you
know did you say yes would you say
that's you can't do that right I do that
you that that'll be that's called
crossing the line is it
yeah it's called crossing well can I get
a large cup of joe and a dick sake no no
that's called crossing the line I'm
sorry buddy sent me here I guess it's
not on the menu no put your [ __ ] and
balls in my mouth I guess it's on the
menu I can hit the scramble and a dick
side yeah no see that he's not on the
menu is that my main reason and you're
what's called a problem customer and
you'll be escorted out no she was just
have you ever been in a situation where
somebody was so rude to the to somebody
helping them that you stepped in and
said something to the person I was
dating this girl won't say her name a
lot of people no she is not who you're
thinking of either Julia Roberts
I don't know correct I think I heard the
51 year old right Ellen Barkin Brian
Ellen and we're on a date and she's
treating this tie we're at Ghent I
finished treating the tie waiter like
[ __ ] like making fun of them yeah and
you tell he's like young kid he's like
all flustered she kept going on it what
are you doing from I even snapped one
what are you doing
the [ __ ] you doing never saw again after
that yeah I can't I'm like what are you
doing I can't abide by that no that does
that's that woman who wrote that book
said if you want to know how the guy's
gonna treat you later on the
relationship watch how he treats the
waitstaff I mean I guess no those habits
they run deep
maybe me I get base all of them yeah I'm
like you did a shitty job still gonna
always need to so I'm like that's that's
a tough gig here's 20 percent yeah and
you know Jay the old penny pincher Jay
you don't know do you only get 20% like
yeah come on man he's a waiter for God's
sakes
well Rogen does that Rogan I'll give
Rogan said to me I was tipping and he
goes give him give him a hundred bucks
or something like that and I was like
it's your bet it was a $40 I was like I
know I know but imagine if you had to do
that it's like but he's a young guy
it's like my uber driver in Chicago this
guy was awesome he's talking her ear off
and he's just hilarious you seen how he
lost his dad as dad's a piece of [ __ ]
he's like doing jokes about his dad when
you're laughing and he's like you know
he was and he was I'm a hustler he got
real hustle I'm a hustler man and you
know no one drives more over than me you
know when they say oh you can make this
much money in uber there's a there's a
[ __ ] cap it was you couldn't pick up
more people you couldn't put more cars
in a day than what I do every single day
you know what the cap is it's $200 a day
you make $200 a day here's I make a
grand a week you can't and he goes UNAM
[ __ ] easier he gets around [ __ ] grind
then he goes that's as much you make you
as otherwise it won't be a [ __ ]
Hoover driver yeah because you're not
making hundreds of thousands of dollars
here's I make this much every week they
might give me a bonus buy it
certain things into extra $60 that makes
my [ __ ] week yeah he was leader Vegas
anything else is young is anything else
right Greg oh I didn't ask you that
means I know but [ __ ] it and he was that
too before it
he was I'm trying to get
I mean naming the other place he goes so
I don't have to do this [ __ ] cuz
they told me I can make hundreds of
thousand dollars she goes there's that
cap their second cap I'm in Hawaii like
dude the the the reason why I brought
the story because then I got done and
he's telling me how big of a deal that
the bonus that they give you every week
yeah so I give them a fatass
tip but you can only give a certain
amount how much the ride is right but
our ride cuz we'd stayed death in
Chicago and we're driving to Schaumburg
every day which like an hour you can tip
them pretty good based off that right
ending him out yeah that's always a good
way to go I am I'm in Hawaii
well you donated that one lady $50 yeah
yeah she's and she's lucky to get yeah
I'm in Hawaii I call I'm with my wife my
two kids my mother-in-law and then some
me and my father-in-law yeah no no no my
sister so long story short it's a lot of
people I call an uberx I'm gonna get our
SUV a Cadillac pulls a brand new
Cadillac
those are nice those new ones I don't
know what that was or was this something
like that some was an SUV dad Dan see I
guess maybe eat it yeah right look that
was like damn that's a nice looking car
so um we get in and he goes like this
the guy goes first of all I look at his
eyes and they are like this we know he
smoked weed and your eyes get really red
his were blood out of his peepers his
peepers had like he was blinking blood
he was blinking blood I was like he
looked like one of those evil hamsters
with the red eyes
I was like did somebody poked your eyes
did somebody just poke her I mean did
you sleep in sawdust what the [ __ ] is
going on and they were all they're all
tiny so he goes I'll get about five
tickets here yeah I didn't know this is
many people I go really cuz yeah
he goes yeah yeah I go okay well what do
you want to do two guys I can only say
four men so I'm like alright this guy's
already like my wife my wife he just
hears and she goes I'm out see ya I'll
get another thing just gets out I think
takes my daughter my mother-in-law who
misses nothing she okay's loans so she
personal loans so she knows she didn't
do it for 30 years she hears every sob
story she knows everything she's really
smart about that and then my lovable so
it's four of us
this guy I'm sitting next to him in the
car
this guy starts talking to me about how
he makes $3 a ride and he can't he can't
break even he's got this insanely
expensive car then he starts to tell me
that he can't really hold the steering
wheel is probably the thing I used to
work on boats I got involved in this
paint and the paint screwed me up so it
broke my hands apart and I have I guess
he goes I guess sir I swear to god he
goes I get psoriasis of the eyes now I
know this is called finessing yeah yeah
and I hear my mother go cheese yeah so
so he goes yeah I just can't do it I go
back and forth it is where it is and I
go so I go so what are you doing he goes
well
see how my skin breaks apart I get
psoriasis also of my hands and I have
also eczema so my skin is all broken but
I'm taking a new medication but the man
Vegas but the medication no he goes I'm
sorry because his pants were broken
apart he goes the medication gives me
pinkeye of no foxes the medication it
keeps my hands are breaking apart too
much in my skin but it makes my long
story short el pinkeye III I get $100
bill $100 bail
my mother-in-law wrote was she goes that
guy was so full of [ __ ] for nursing
your bro it worked bro the pink guys but
you know what obey your hundred dollars
to end this story when you got Hanson or
cracked up and full of wounds and you
got I mean they get me too though I'm a
sucker I'm a sucker I believe them yeah
you know I mean when I'll stand out I'll
stand out and look at the bums though
I'll stand out there and look at him see
how much money everyone's giving to him
like that look him up and down well see
if they're an addict I won't donate till
I talk to a guy who makes fifty seven
dollars a day dude I told you in Venice
when I was a kid you grew up around
there
in the summers and we would see dudes
the guy who like walking on glass or
swallow [ __ ] or do the flips and they
were out there like hustling so I'm
jumping afterwards he right where we
stayed you jump in a brand new [ __ ]
s-class Mercedes no I've off my dad like
I don't get how people don't understand
that he's making much money cash non-tax
he's not on d-day
in the middle of summer bombing yeah
yeah well just why I want to work on my
juggling game you like to do an act out
there what could we do better in the kid
presents nothing actually not a lot you
could you would be so pathetic you know
what we do if we had to right now you
would like curl me I'd make my body
super strong curl me or lift me over
your head yeah see this strong guy lifts
this other 51 year old you'd be like
we'd be like real shitty version of
penteli yeah I work at I work out with a
dad bod yeah bwin yeah look at these
guys Tom worst they like jump over their
singers we can't really sing but those
kind of like street performers have
always existed throughout all the time
always been if you want the best street
performers most run third street now
they get a little fancier stuff third
Street now yeah yeah they did though
like the real talented like musicians
are in third Street I think they get
higher income there I'm not sure but
they've taken their business their chin
I've never thought about singing on
Third Street
that's so funny provider brought that up
you did it over the weekend huh now did
you kill three people it's not over the
weekend but when I was in a group we
wanted to perform there and there was
already an established group there that
took a section Korean group Mexican
group
oh this so like West Side Story yeah so
they took theirs they're stationed there
and we're just like we're you know which
is up-and-coming group can we use your
mics just for like a minute to do a song
oh they're like nah man we pay to be
here which would whatever so yeah deaf
program permits paid everything really
yeah you look like you're getting ready
for the fight cuz you look like you're
in shape they've been working action I
don't work out a little bit
I've been jogging now too he's been
quiet about it too so his body's
responding you walk by me and you look
tighter a little bit mmm you just
stopped eating shakes action I haven't
been there now when I say this in
Chicago I ate all the deep-dish pizza
did I look like chinch twin brother in
the face house okay
hey all the deep-dish yeah all the I
went on stage I told everyone I'm before
we start this thing I'd be honest I
might [ __ ] my pants up there I do not
feel well but I'm out here anyways yeah
I want some sort of applaud for that you
couldn't help yourself well we got all
these in your mouth just water just now
yeah
we know we all these recommendations man
went to one place where Al Capone was
cooped up with his boys st. Valentine's
Day master yeah and their that the pizza
is right there
and it was so [ __ ] delicious that's
the pizza Oh dude who still that looks
like somebody punched
that's awesome serious until they died
yeah I know I'm gonna take a bloody face
but it's delicious so what is that it's
like a it's a deep dish like a bowl they
put they put in this bowl Wow
and then they flip it over it was
amazing man that that's and of course
mean shark eyes daal small J Shaab went
to Gibson's it ain't the [ __ ] beef
sliders hard to argue with games you
know Jays a hater and I might just wait
till this touches your stupid dick
loving lips cuz he was hating on it I
won't wait til your stupid dick lips get
a hold of and you stay at the hut at the
Hobson Thompson that's a great the best
hotel and I told Jay and he went these
are amazing I went right now you're
gonna need these for the next three days
there's no night in your L three days
out wait til tomorrow wait till lunch
rolls around huh
let me think of this steak in your mouth
huh that's a great area - that's called
the viagra triangle I have good triangle
because there's a lot of guys we're
gentlemen my agent older who hang out
there divorcees and all the ladies of
the evening you can see them they
descend the ladies and they're not in
the 20s they're in the 30s and they're
professionals Cougars down there's great
shopping around there - yeah yeah and
there's these Ferraris Lambos everywhere
yeah it's a good time or a lot of a lot
of money come by I agree sir and
everyone say that to a - all yesterday
at the viagra circle yeah
viagra triangle though why I called the
circle and he got it wrong he's from
Chicago
so I'll bet you you didn't that's not
what he said you got it right you know
when you're right you're right but now
it's like a triangle yeah that's right
and it is a glorious place yeah it is
it's beautiful oh there it is look at
that right there
yep great shopping I thought you know
that I've never needed Viagra or Cialis
but now I'm tempted because I hear you
can you can keep it going for a long
time I've never taken it either no you
know what you know it doesn't it doesn't
entice me I don't want a boner for 24
hours right I know I remember what sixth
grade was like you know it's annoying
[ __ ] yes I had to tuck that thing up
like a telescope yeah but have the head
peek out the top like you goddamn loch
ness monster yep
I don't want that head tuck my head just
act raring to go
veins pulsating did you ever do this
when you were a kid why would you need
it Brian I'm just I'm saying never get
oh no I know why you're 51 the old dicks
let me guess
hitting the snooze but it's not true
it's just that hey no I'm saying I've
never done it but I but I look forward
to when I there are a couple things that
are gonna happen when I'm 55 and I'm
gonna tell you this right now your
[ __ ] gets extra loose no there's just
farting on command like Larry King on TV
no nobody just farting nowheres mean
hearing you're sure that's not me go
dude you know why you just farted you
have no idea
that's not why be boogers we'll just
follow your nose okay that's what
happens when you're older
no hey your ears are gonna continue to
grow and they look weird as we speak no
because he you're here we'll go see ya
it's already kind of hanging out you're
saying all this because I have I have an
anecdote Olga and your nose will also
grow longer I'm gonna get on
testosterone
that's your encourage it to grow I don't
think so I think testosterone is gonna
keep me very young and very tight and we
carry on and then there's something you
can take that tricks your body into
producing human growth hormone without
taking him and that's not real no it's a
doctor into it I know you're talkin my
friend does it I just take HGH you're
full of [ __ ] doing that because pop hg
because it could be like hey this tiny
tumor that's never gonna grow into
anything
thanks for the HGH and then then you got
to be too much but even you take that
stuff to increase your HGH that's gonna
be the same thing maybe it is yeah but
what I'm saying you just oh dude I don't
get why I just don't come out and say
hey everybody I've dick problems this is
a cry for help and you have problems
with your penis I don't I really don't
and I'm surprised that at 51 I don't I'm
surprised more energy with anyone I can
still kind of diamond with my dog get
more energy than anyone I know
how about if he has known this when I
was in New York Brown was in New York I
got finished taping the watch what
happens live with Andy Cohen for Bravo
show debuts tonight play-by-play a
Pacific Bravo
watch it awesome I have a lot of family
members code you know picked it is
welcome
anyways uh yeah I don't watch Bravo or
no nor would you would you don't watch
TV but specially probably yeah but stay
anyways show anyways we were Brian was
literally at a bar next door to where I
was shooting yeah next door Wow I met
Brian there and we'd get done yes we did
and our boy our boy Lee who listens to
the podcast on a regular basis good dude
Lee's a joker Lee is a small person he
is about he's a he's not very PC about
it cuz hey I go lead a snack like Lee
doesn't get Lee's about like three three
feet something and he works all time a
really good actor
he was a game of three I can't believe I
just look it up
Liam find a B you don't have to do it
let you try to do it yeah I don't know
if there we go legal big deal but um
well you know I did I didn't know how to
do I don't I'm not used to a small
person so I wait he does it bother you
when people say or you know do they
treat you like this and he goes Brian
bronchitis brine list this [ __ ] guy
asked me it's insulting they call me a
small percent war for like now ya know
give a [ __ ] and he by the way he does
not he that guy has game he's getting
he'll put it on you as a woman his
girlfriend who's shown fictive his
ex-girlfriend she was from Holland or
something she's about she's about six
five okay you I give a [ __ ] but it was
funny one of things I didn't around it's
been a good amount of time with him one
things I noticed being around them is
that when you're a small person like
that everybody goes out of their way to
be really nice and loud about it to you
and car stop and let you pass and it
gets exteriors and it gets exhausting it
gets exhausting cuz he's constantly
having to tell people I get it you're
not gonna treat me differently he said
it's family raisin like just don't like
they're like you're no different your
old bread can do it you can put that was
a military guy that was like this real
friendly killers girl awesome is that
how hot it is boy is boy who else listen
to podcast tale
his suits so whenever he has a premiere
it's [ __ ] great yeah I love it
probably packing a piece too do you
think I want to ask him it's all normal
that for somebody who's a small person
you know I know from Brad Williams that
that I've seen Brad's piece and it's
normal PS it's actually well probably
looks like a goddamn flute very well at
the front of his belly yeah that's yeah
in fact in my my look impossibly large
you look really nice though yeah good
man talented talented good actor the
Joker
Joker's gonna be special huh there's
rumors going around you see that try I
posted the trailer of Joaquin Phoenix as
the Joker and it is some creepy [ __ ] I'm
not allowed to say anything but I will
say this about about the movie go to
that trailer chinna those words are a
lot of actors and I've never seen
anybody work on this level the way
Joaquim does I've never seen him look at
have you seen this yeah it's incredibly
he gets this is so [ __ ] cool
[Music]
he's as good he's as good as it gets
oh it's one of the best perfect Joker I
was so blown away by how the way he
works it was what 20 me is how how
sensitive people are like that's not the
real Joker the makeup looks like [ __ ]
Heath Ledger the rascal sends us murder
it's like shadows fraud wait just wait
but also get your cheesy cheeto fingers
off the keyboard he's gonna be good well
that's the thief ledger was it great
this movies been so secretive that's why
when we were out when we were walking
out to your trailer there are paparazzi
everywhere already taking pictures
there's a funny picture of you have you
seen it yes have you seen it a lot
you got a bat up yeah and all you that's
all that happens because there did these
these fanboys all for the recap yeah
dude and they wanted people were DM me
like do you know exactly what Bryan's
characters do you know what I'm like
blood and I decide on Indiana so I told
everyone yeah I told everyone what your
character what I've already said too
much on that podcast before I sell well
I [ __ ] up myself to give him the plot
away two years ago yes you did and I got
in trouble for it's alright that's
alright it is what it is
someone said it to me too yeah I'm a
sexy looking guy um either way it was
it's pretty cool it's pretty cool do you
see that what speaking of sensitive
[ __ ] did you see I posted that Bert
and Ernie that the only camera said they
were gay I said uh no [ __ ]
in other news Gonzo's blue now your
thoughts of course they were gay yeah go
to that for me down whatever dude they
live together they live together again
my only they slept together so my only
problem with it not problem but a gay
dude won't have that unibrow they're
usually pretty oh you don't say if
that's the only thing where I'm like I
don't know ha but the comp people are so
upset that they would even mention that
these two are gay like oh so now our
puppets we have to demand their
sexuality why do we even care it's a
kids show well Kermit and [ __ ] Miss
Piggy we're hooking up we didn't
question that there's no problem with
that I don't give up [ __ ] that these
what's going on are they a Sesame Street
bringing these saying that they're gay
now I'd so much sum one of the creators
came out or someone that something do it
said yeah I wrote them in mind of the
his he was gay and that there's
something like that and then the actual
creator of some she was like no they
weren't gay so but either who cares so
Bert and Ernie [ __ ] each other off who
cares yeah I don't know why anyone kids
I don't know why it's a big deal
throw some puppets also puppet yeah it's
all some puppets the guy that's on the
couch there so holy someone goes oh I
assumed all puppets are gay and then and
I go you tell me you never thought about
this and in this guy goes nah man
[ __ ] nah he goes [ __ ] nah I shut there
are really good friends like stay the
night each other house all the time
having thought of it since I was a kid
but not you mention it I still don't
think that kid gosh [ __ ] no hell no I
remember one time I was in my 20s and we
were all drinking and my my friend who
was just you know that that friend is
just giant and hairy and but just nice
like I just he's just the big blond big
bear yeah and a big sensitive bear oh
yeah he got drunk and I'm sleeping and I
wake up and I can just hear crawled into
my bed overall we were all staying in a
cabin and he was sleeping next to me and
I was like I don't want to sleep I can
smell you and I can hear you [ __ ]
breathing Wow
get me the [ __ ] outta here [ __ ] you now
yeah well no we ended up dating but I
still I was like get off there it is
leave Ryan look at the arms on me look
at a farmer's tan but if you're here
though dude why not go rap cool can I
keep this wig that's an expensive wig I
know we keep it yeah you look sexy as
[ __ ] there dude you look 20 years
younger I know five good hair dude came
here though dude I know you that doesn't
entice you to get a wig no Brandon it
doesn't it doesn't
no it doesn't do you tell handsome you
are it hey did I mention ask me what I
did this weekend speaking of hair Wi-Fi
in New York what would you do
going surfing oh did you really yeah
who'd you go with a big wave rider named
Kyle Taryn was that fun
all right I mean now you can't surf so
it's a bad idea to go big wave surf I
got a bum oh yeah I got are you are
going on
wait no oh I told me the spot I know
surfing right in Venice Oh No
and and anyways and I was riding baby
wave beginner ways beginner waves yeah
okay that he was catching for me yeah
and some of the waves are were like
normal out there yes bill couple spills
I drank them about six gallons of
seawater I feel like there's nothing
better for your body than that oh maybe
not I felt fantastic and I got up I got
up on the wave and I was like okay I get
this it was pretty I don't say big wave
surfing though yeah with this he goes
you want to go tonight it was just
better well I wasn't no no definitely
not because of the great whites he does
our cheese is one of those he serves he
serves no in sanik I know why are those
guys I wish I could do it that much you
know when I first moved here I went
three four times a week surfing you
ain't told me Tony Jefferies go add my
own board my custom board I feel like
it's so big that it must be hard for you
but no you get up on the way everyone's
like oh you're a paddle boarding like
surfing [ __ ] it's my board was so big
yeah it was file of the workout though I
love the ocean we go down to Malibu we
go down to Rodgers we'd go on some
big-ass waves had no business being in
those big wave really dangerous
that's not thinking like well Tony's
from England can't swim or surf oh my
god I really can't we I've never had
lessons and and you were catching some
pretty big waves catching like I'd get
up and then fall off yeah catch them and
then get destroyed by the wave their
attack okay when I first moved to LA and
the countdown shows here I forget who I
was fighting maybe was Mitrione or so on
and the countdown show is here and like
so we see a cover your date we hear your
surfer llama camps are a lot like that'd
be great coverage you get you start from
like cool let's do that hey do you have
a camera guy goes so so you can't like
actually surf or do you just kind of
paddle out there and then I went well no
this is my surfing us we can't use any
of this okay he's in it my bout spent
the whole day fall I had a weird I had
one of the things that ruined my might
surfing time which is sounds where there
is Cal turn a beast rising huge waves
and pro surfer and sponsored by
Patagonia etc it gives TED talks good
luck so so see how he's holding the
board like that he's holding it like
that so you put it on your arm and you
hold it with one arm but the fins have
to be POI
certain way whatever the case we were on
big board ok the size of a Buick cuz I'm
a beginner yeah yeah you fight at a 10
foot board that's right yeah so he shows
up with a board and he's holding it
right like that this is like a bar so
same same board Oh same board yes I
can't
we're same height my arms wouldn't reach
I couldn't carry it that way yeah my
[ __ ] arms are too short you don't
have Genet a first time my life I
realize I have short arms oh really yes
you know you're built like a t-rex no I
didn't know that I thought wow I thought
I thought I had reach I mags don't I
pick on you yeah no you're not breed if
I reach value t-ray I got short legs and
short arms no skinny t-rex dude they got
long light short arms I don't likes to
know not for your body not for my body
but in comparison and comparison to who
[ __ ] cheeky like height my height is
man ago you might look much taught
you're taller and I thought that's cuz
I'm exactly 1/8 off of 1/8 inch off of 6
feet with my shoes on that's I've done
with my shoes off I've been measured you
have a big head my no my height is in my
torso and my neck no I have long held
your head you'll have a long neck no big
head you have a long haired dude I have
a long head yeah all right so my height
samogon a cat my kunzite I tried to see
that little board he has there yeah I
thought like I was getting up on the
Venice waves you think you're all good
sure so I want to go rent a board and I
go give me that one it looked all sweet
my guys like really give me that one
first of all when you're a white belt in
surfing don't rent the black board now I
when I say I didn't get up once it was
like I was on soap I I mean I could mean
any time I couldn't even stand on it I
mean I can do anything the entire day
Tony could not stop laughing but I was
exhausted its exhaust such a good
workout I was out there was and I miss
it man
when I say surfing I love paddling out
there and falling down I love it
what's he do it sometimes Bryan Ortega
is very good at it and his ski know he
is the black belt surfing clothing
company oh he's very good surfing
tanners you know goes with him they
always asked me to go but they do to
bigger waves I can't die man yeah not
since ever
scary I wish I was really good at
surfing otega is a [ __ ] all-american
timepiece really dude look and he surfs
and he can kick your ass really good
surfer jeez like really really good
surfer him and her a really good surfers
yeah you just come out with spam would
toss you in the big wave you'll learn
bro I'm like well no I don't want to do
that you a cat you ever surf I feel like
you'd be good certainly little Leon
stitch or some [ __ ] up there that's
traceable no I like a little one stitch
oh they're like you look like an athlete
um I used to power left a little
oh damn with em chase you Brian does
love powerlifting chick I mean it's not
you but like I didn't mean I mean well I
mean girls like you mean dudes who lift
I didn't mean to go oh yeah I like an
atom at Adam's apple and big in a big
[ __ ] and of defense nutsack I like the
Halloween girls cats would you get hurt
in powerlifting um a few months ago I
don't know exactly what happened I think
I lost a tightness in my core while I
was squatting 225 I got up and I was
[ __ ] my back is shot tweaked your back
yep
and I'm too asian to go to a doctor cuz
I know I didn't snap anything cause you
do the holistic approach and were like
putting like I don't Tiger Claw on your
back or some [ __ ]
uh no I'm just waiting till it goes away
that's smart
that usually helps that usually helps
but so you don't you don't lift or
anything now if good Jeanette no I I
left but not powerlifting anymore I
gotta lift in the Sun
Ted oh wait until I get my powerless I
can just work out hmm I can't just work
out well you're like snatching [ __ ] I
mean that's one thing that everybody
says to me who really knows exercise
that when you know I'm doing deadlift or
I'm if you're doing like snatch and
clean and clean
you better know exactly what you're
doing and and you better have perfect
your technique better be hello buddy
gets her clothes everybody doesn't make
sense
it better be flawless flawless I don't
guys me do it for 15 years they're my
flawless technique this yeah so how
about you two should do it no my this
guy who owns a tempest and a bunch of
gyms they're parkour gyms so
professional stuntmen go there Oh guys
that jump off the walls and stuff no but
it's also stuntman with a
brain for stuff so it's crazy do like
flips it's an amazing facility and it's
packed with kids all the time I bet but
he said to me he goes okay as I was
jumping on the trampoline and he goes
okay so there's zero reason for you to
jump super high in your life at 51
there's no reason and also there's no
reason to be doing backflips or anything
else like you'll never have to do that
so don't did you say no [ __ ] to him why
would one know cuz I asked him about a
backflip that's weird yeah wait what
were you doing there I took my son man
okay yeah there it is right there
thank God you take credit man it's
actually great for kids they love it and
they have instructors and stuff yeah you
can't begin hurt man I don't want to be
getting sick my son cigarette now my god
goes around but he's sick man I feel
like it's that time we I can't afford to
get sick man me neither
i gargle with salt water like a
[ __ ] that's supposed to help I
feel like chin sick year-round their
allergies Soph you're around year-round
why don't you take something people like
I should take some back shop I'm just
like her I don't go to the hospital I
have to go to the house and I'm not
saying go to the hospital get your nose
removed just take and spray no nothing
works for me so I gotta go get tested
and see what see exactly causing it but
my nose is running constantly now really
but especially when I'm in this building
mm-hmm yeah there's dogs in this
building there's like animals in this
building there might be a nose to
chemicals combinations of chemicals all
the time so it's one thing to have a
chemical that's safe but then what it
what happens when you combine it with 17
other chemicals I feel great I like this
place you don't have any allergies
I'm lucky you know I've like looks like
grass and [ __ ] but I'm not allergic
office buildings not the building I
think it's the carpets yeah it might be
yeah but uh grass and you play football
yep
so you got sick of looking through
Tarawa lose your grass grass shrubs on
my skin it gets all splotchy and bubbly
that happens to a lot of people when you
roll out of grass with your shirt off
yeah it's super fun yeah yeah
I'm looked like pollens and [ __ ]
remember I ran through as a kid I ran to
I think it was something poison
boys no boys but i-i've I felt it
immediately I felt it boys anoke no [ __ ]
man it was an IV yeah that hits ASA Wow
a solely [ __ ] that was some of that I
remember that pain I was probably seven
or eight and I still remember it did you
have your eight chicken wings to rub
your eyes on excellent you ever done
that my friend I've had chicken wings
and you know the the the hot sauce gets
in between your fingers cuz your [ __ ]
finger licking good yeah and then hours
later hours yeah I'll be in the hotel
room let's go Jesus Christ oh [ __ ] in
Fuego in my eyeball look at that I'm a
donkey like Mike a [ __ ] friend had sex
in the bushes with a man and somewhere
in Cape Cod or something and got himself
caught up in some poison ivy and got it
all over his dong and his ass and
everywhere else oh yeah I had to go to
the emergency room three times that
might be Jesus discipling them three
times you had to go look at this tear
that's psoriasis that's poison ivy bro
Jesus Christ man like plants out there
that can do some [ __ ] to you plant
snakes and Coral there's coral when I
was in Tahiti guys like we went we went
to scuba diving uh so here's the thing
everybody scuba dive it's beautiful I
want you to not touch anything
cuz when you touch certain things down
there it can be usually this well
there's some enjoy that enjoy that yeah
that'll [ __ ] yeah
Yellowstone how about old chin here
speaking of things you shouldn't touch
how about Chin's coming to a Seattle
what does that mean don't touch you
don't say Jays be touching to see how
I'm getting the fellas a heads up don't
touch chin
don't touch to kill you got and take
that too well yeah good shows in
Schaumburg yeah get shows it's just
zombies in the middle of nowhere in our
great crowds yeah great good people are
alive stay in Chicago and just drive in
and you gotta stay in Chicago in
Schaumburg ballsed act right price did
tell you horny yeah yeah I understand I
don't think I've ever been a part of
your life though you're gonna love it
yeah it's not Seattle you're in Bellevue
it's but it's technically it's right
like but you know Buster lives in
Seattle
yeah I'm like Bell v's Ike it's where
you want to be you say it's a great spot
yeah you don't think so
it's usually it's the Microsoft
headquarters oh it's not Seattle but
it's close enough great crowds close
enough they say yes it is I went to
Seattle here's a story for Seattle and
though I have two times the last I went
to I did show and I was invited out by
people about my age now when you're in
your 50s 40s and 50s you know you go to
a party and I went to this beautiful
house in Seattle yeah they invited me to
this day so we're having them house
party I had nothing to do they said come
by and I got along with the dude I was
talking to a cool guy sounds like you
know I'm God I'm not tired I'll be a
little lonely I'll go I Drive my rental
car there when I tell you that all these
people my age you know we're doing rails
of cocaine in CLO bro just yeah
everybody and I was like are you [ __ ] I
mean to the point where they're shaking
you ever talk to somebody and they're
their foot is doing this and I was like
I gotta get the [ __ ] out of the land of
the vampires I don't know who had the
house it we had to have been a five
million dollar house or something every
single person with the exception of me
was just just doing just rail after
wheel and offering me I was like I gotta
have a fun party though no no because no
I don't want to be around a bunch of
coke fiends who and waiting for
somebody's heart to stop Jesus yeah not
a good idea
so I robbed everybody you robbed other
things yeah I like Seattle Seattle
Vancouver Portland it's kind of if you
put it all together he said hey over in
Serena you don't like the
north-northwest
I think it's overrated oh wow I think
it's too rainy I think it's too great
you hate on San Fran - a little bit
though
I like San Fran you I mean we've you
paid it on a little bit though have I
yeah it's overrated a little bit I like
Northern California I love nap I love
that area but I'd live up the hundred
percent but um and there are parts of
San Francisco of course you could live
in but overall yeah so
the more I travel and thank God for
stand-up I've seen this world I've seen
North America I can never have before
because I fly in a town I'm in town for
three four days I see the city I meet
the people I eat the best restaurants
hotels I walked the city I'd let you
learn the city when I was playing
football fighting I fly and I don't see
[ __ ]
right moms will be playing in Iraq sure
fly play on the plane out it doesn't
matter where we're at but now do to
stand up I'm Lily all over the city
food everything's great and the more I
travel the more the big cities that go
to smart markets I do not think live in
the big cities the way to go and for a
guy like me to admit that it's insane
but I'm like oh [ __ ] no this I don't
want you know what that you know you
know what happens what really happened
yet kids table was growing up yet kids
pop was growing up yeah well cuz cuz now
I'm in a stage where I'm taking my son
to soccer tennis yeah all that see how
to get around
I gotta get around it boy he's got Cub
Scouts my daughter had Girl Scouts mmm
you're driving you spending a lot of
time with that raising that child and
giving them those experiences yep
the big cities I don't know man
uh I have this fantasy of living in the
country with a large yard and my big
German Shepherd and four dudes or what
what no I don't know here you go with
this that sounds rather poor uh what do
you mean for do we said fantasy it's not
a fantasy
I feel fantasy mean just four guys gonna
a KERS just know that fantasy of having
like a like a farm like a house and just
like people and then the four guys and
just me and having dinners and me yeah
and then watch the movies and we can't
leave now we're just like monkey chow
Cheyenne bad you know I mean dude ain't
no home no home alone but would it be
cool if you like you and your four best
friends they're like a giant bed you
guys all lived together though yeah just
you guys want to let's all turn in guys
yeah oh you better not even slow down we
all have our chicks bro yeah I just say
we're all wearing a big bed
Rogers yanking it again dammit where are
the tissues yeah like look at that bad
have you ever heard of these custom bed
I've looked at you I'm a psycho I've
looked into the the problem is getting
the custom sheets not cheap but you can
you didn't get these matches like yours
gotta cost you though fifty thousand no
they're not terrible you leave about
twelve fifteen grand just for the
mattress okay that's a lot of money
that's a giant [ __ ] mattress look at
that though everybody sleeps well that
looks like two kings they put together
it's gonna be like [ __ ] I love a giant
bed though yeah we got one with the
pizza it's pretty cool I forget what
they're called but they're it's not
California lion pads it's called it's
called [ __ ] it's called family it's
all it's called the bed of four dudes
no y'all have this fancy just getting
like a ton of land ultra bed and me and
four dudes just out there no but I'm not
I'm not talking I going that far I'm
talking like Topanga Topanga Woodland
Hills yeah and that's why people poop
out there and I used to make fun of Rogi
I'm like dude you living with your
shrekt you live in the middle of [ __ ]
nowhere and as I get older my goddamn
man and you go to Montana you know you
go to certain parts of the of the flower
Rogen's he pulled some broccoli out of a
[ __ ] pot that was growing quickly huh
just pulled some broccoli cut some
broccoli out of a pot on that deck threw
some elk on I was like this best meal
I've ever had in my life
see it says Cal franking there's like a
Hungarian king or some [ __ ] like that's
huge that's incredible right there yeah
that's incredible your room would have
to be so big yeah not to be wall-to-wall
that's a big room
I'd like that though they'd be a let me
answer this question mean Jay were
talking about this and ask chin this
question I'm below the belt so I watched
that documentary say I was 34 30 junior
sale
yeah who's my favorite player as a kid
growing up cried during it and so he he
died he commits suicide at the age of 43
so but do it and I think I know what
answer you have but just hear me out
here so let's say as a kid you grew up
you're a five-star recruit you're you're
the celebrity good-looking dude you're
jr. sale then in your blue chip
all-american in high school you get a
full ride scholarship from Oceanside
to Southern California USC doesn't get
any bigger football
then from USC you're the number five
pick in the NFL Draft you're born to
play for your perennial all-pro one of
the best linebackers to ever put a
helmet on you're a hall-of-famer you
you're a Super Bowl ring holder
everything you have the best credit of
all time yeah you live made millions and
millions of dollars yeah but you died at
43 yeah another have that or be Joe
Schmo slubbing away for the man average
life live in the burbs you're making 60
grand a year
and not that anything's wrong with this
I'm just painting the two dynamics here
making 60 grand a year normal family you
shall wait for happy hour there was
anyone that you lived uh you live to 80
yeah would you rather have that life for
this 43 so so if there is anyone who is
made to play football I'm asking all the
sanno Percy Nasia of course yeah no [ __ ]
I'm asking you I believe that you rather
you believe the juice is worth the
squeeze
you'd rather grabbing a shield at 43 s
then play it safe in Libya
I think everybody should I mean this is
my personal opinion I believe this is
gonna sound I'm gonna quote Nietzsche
here that I'm but I really mean this
your life should be a work of art and
your life should be passionate and
sometimes when you live a passionate
life and you follow your passion winces
their consequences heavy [ __ ] whether
you're a fighter with you're a football
player whatever is my painter an artist
I'd be bro artist look comedian you
might be broke dude all of it a lot of
great artists a lot of great painters
were broke we're miserable died early
van Gogh etc I would I don't want to
live in a world without those people a
lot of great writers were selfish pricks
I don't want to live I don't want to
live in a world without those people and
so you have to go on your shield yes
yeah yes I've always felt that way I
made that decision when I was a very
young man when I chose to be an actor
yeah chose to be a comic chose to do
what I do and I have no regrets and I I
I think that's a hard case and we love
them of course you don't want him to be
crazy like that there are a lot of guys
that did play football for a long time
that that you know don't suffer from
that and this was a every case is unique
so I don't know what to say about it but
yes I do believe that it was worth it
another guy I'm saying
I'm saying for me not for him I don't
know but I'm saying I believe that that
should not that should not have people
say I have a dream I have all the towel
in the world I'm not gonna do it but I
say no I agree I agree hung up so I
really believe that yeah playing it safe
and playing it sensible has a place but
not it's not not if it's getting I don't
know where I feel I don't know where and
you're talking about you played football
for sorry playing football when I was
four I stopped playing my last year of
college then when you're in the pros is
what's that I don't know damn near 20
years and fought for what seven I don't
know man you feel do you feel you have
brain damage do you feel you have memory
loss
do you feel anything no do you think
you're an impulsive person yes to the
question yes yes but so am i yeah when I
be and I don't I don't
but yeah I don't I don't know if I'm
ever will see down the road but like his
his uh so they ran a three-four defense
his other middle linebackers guy named
Gary Plummer and he's in this
documentary and he has severe brain
trauma two years Alzheimer's I think
down he's a real prompt to dementia in
dementia he has a check check check and
a fat face and so he wasn't doing well
on the dock either and I remember
watching him and he was saying you don't
have problems too so I I don't know like
is he gonna come down the road here's
the other thing though here's the other
thing with junior sail he is my all-time
favorite athlete number one hands down
not even close I [ __ ] love junior
sail there they are Gary Plummer he was
a little thick there he got stung by all
the bees like me at that time so anyways
he the thing with junior too that I
think might have a little something to
do with it sped up his his movie the
ending of his movie dying commit suicide
when he got done playing football there
was no other passion project for him
there was nothing to steer all that
energy you have to take
and I almost I want and I almost hate
when people say oh look at Brendan's
work ethic it's from as aesthetic days
that doesn't really work because I know
guys who have better workout words work
ethics I mean that aren't athletes
I know athletes have to work at the
worst work ethic you've ever seen they
just really good at that yes that sport
so that doesn't really work so with
junior sayo though he had that crazy
work ethic and he wanted to do something
with that energy but didn't have
anywhere to point it yeah so you see him
retire and then come out and go come
back to New England Patriots
whenever Sohn retires and then they come
back it's the they want to come back
it's a crisis like when you have when
people go dude when are you fine again
not [ __ ] advert you never sparring
ever never never because I found
something else to channel this all this
energy I have yeah I've had the same
energy that's the same way I am now huge
I've always been like this and now it's
all towards this I'm not gonna go over
here that's just that's such a huge
point man because so I think it was that
a lot of the brain trauma it makes what
is his crazy style of bedding mix with
some other a lot of athletes from sports
that don't have brain trauma in them
suffer from the same issue when they
stop doing there sport it is it is there
are a lot of stories his regimen for the
walk going through depression correct
well I talked to Matt best the boys that
black rifle coffee shot at the black
gravel cafe Matt Beth and the dudes make
the best damn cup of joe in the world
but I asked them I went hey PTSD goes
videos very similar football right like
you have your strength cases there are
guys absolutely have it's [ __ ]
terrible man
and a lot of them do have it then
there's some guys who get done and
they're done chasing the Dragons tail
and they get home and you go here work a
nine-to-five send that off so you're
holed up
I was a sniper yeah in the [ __ ]
Marines yes I was on the rooftops
chasing out out Kip al Qaeda you want me
to sit there and give you TPA report yes
[ __ ] this and they get all super
depressed I had an experience dad comes
out with athletes to you yeah you talked
to an athlete a mixed martial artist who
goes hold up I was training to fight the
best athletes in the world I'd walk out
to the cage and fight the very best in
front of millions of people
now you want me to sell [ __ ] Jamba
Juice of course und this happen this
happens with uh with soldiers with
people who've been through war when I
was in Afghanistan the guy who took us
around was a decorated recon marine had
been in Vietnam and it spent a lot of
time was still in the war theater and we
had another guy there that was kind of
coordinating things and he was a
civilian to work for the DoD but he the
Department of Defense but he wasn't a
soldier but a retired range and he took
tranquilizers and he wasn't things were
tough for him and I got known he's a
ranger yeah typical spirit and and this
guy said to me my buddy said I know a
lot of guys like that who can't stop
they still need to be close to the flame
so even though even though they've
retired they're not they would think I
wouldn't he had bullet wounds he had he
was hip in the wound you can't go back
don't have to stay closer there's no
going back it's like it would be like
for no one who's ever risk anything like
that like here try this try the best
piece of [ __ ] steak you've ever had
in your life now you never gain that
again now now eat [ __ ] Bologna for
the rest your life it's like what the
[ __ ] it's the juice and also it's it's
also when you're very highly regimented
when you have a highly regimented
schedule and you're told you now you're
just left and it's really that's that's
what college athletes do and a lot of
college kids like when you go to college
you have this strict curriculum you're
going to class your bills are paid
you're not really in the real world and
if you're an athlete double that on top
of it you're majoring expertise need
purpose then you get done and it's like
whoa human beings need purpose and
direction and meaning if you don't have
purpose direction I'm meaning but it's
even worse for these for these athletes
fighters and football players where
everyone's eating out of the palm of
your hand you're getting these huge
paychecks you're the life of the party
seemed to with actors like sometimes
you'll see them mention names but you'll
see actors who really haven't had a hit
show in a while or a movie and we see
them the media freaking out yes why is
that because they want the attention
yeah they they thrive off the attention
all of a sudden TMZ is not coming around
the house and they use these to be the
ones back I can't stand that [ __ ]
whether they love it so they're looking
for that so they do something sporadic
or they punch a photographer or they do
something Cory
yeah assault a police officer correct
like Heather Locklear is correct
she's married oh yeah I know and and
that that that does have to play a
factor that has to play a factor in into
it's it's not all of things a hell of a
drug
things a hell of a drug [ __ ] a lot of
people yes it does and it always ends it
always ends I don't care where you are
so you pissed so hard let's take a break
let's do it do get your leg down bro why
have an American boy always do ya do you
get like corny and waves can you go like
three days and not think about it then
oh yeah then just hit you yeah like a
gust of wind yeah brush my sweat oh my
god they say women when they're
ovulating that which would make sense
they get way more they're way more apt
to have a hookups then and with sort of
alpha male kind of guys dude I don't
know why this just hit me but Yom Kippur
though thank you poor Yom Kippur yes
when I was in New York it was like the
purge in that [ __ ] there was no traffic
no was any restaurants a lot of Jews in
New York forever it was zero is a new
traffic then there were in Israel and I
think that might still be the case for
sure I love Jewish people love them so
my best friend's juice Aidan's Jewish
yeah financier managers they run [ __ ]
anyways Yom Kippur that's the best Iraqi
Jewish New Year is that true
it's Yom Kippur is the year you it's
when you forgive your sins you atone
fierce yes yes but the reason why I'm
bringing it up is the day of us it's the
biggest day right now it's the biggest
you tell me after the Jewish Sabbath
Rosh Hashanah that's right
so as long as the Saturday ask God for
forgiveness for their sins to secure
their faith is also as the Sabbath of
all I'm saying is if you're in New York
I was like so I landed at 3:30
JFK driving the city you look at two
hours traffic and I'm like oh my god I'd
want to [ __ ] jump out this car got
there in 35 minutes like what is there a
bomb scare I don't know it's happening
right now
nope Yom Kippur best day to go there do
zero traffic
walk the restaurant I won just follow on
yarmulke
great time yeah all right what do you
got chin tournament before current
events we've brought some balut eggs and
wanted to know if you could try it on
air what is it
balut with the duck eggs remember the
fertilized I'm telling you right now
there's no way I mean I want to look at
them all right that's not chance of Hell
open I'm gonna open it up hold up chin
yeah you talked about the eggs we had on
last week we were taught as the ones you
guys freaked out about well where'd you
get them first of all I was in Orange
County on the weekend this is also
there's a place of Vietnamese restaurant
or Vietnamese like fast food restaurant
place and then they happen to have them
I'm nervous all right now they big like
like pterodactyl eggs they are these are
actually small have you some smaller
size but they look pretty big you asked
for the smaller size why don't you get
the big ones bro look at these sight
these are huge big enough see cat's
mouth to salivate hangover their chins
nose is starting to run he's also how do
you be beating these before you know how
am I gonna like Don fear factor
I would oh my god those are fat these
are ostrich eggs let me see the one
right you guys want spoons just to crack
it open and see if you want even dude
that's all you see that ass egg bro the
studio you smell like I don't know I
have no how do you smell cat is the
stewardess Mel like a [ __ ] porta
potty and
Vietnam no that would be durian actually
um yeah durian smells hey there it goes
oh you want to be careful dude I'll
throw up it's not that bad
well it's bloody oh god I got angry flip
open open that on his bloody hold on
I wonder if these supposed to you're
supposed to blow god dude oh that's what
it is okay so I bought these eggs I
guess you all right I mean how we get it
though I'm not comfortable with that I I
feel like that that so she how about to
hatch I wonder if they're like they were
gonna die anyways but they were just uh
I don't think so no a living creature
that is a wave one alright we'll move it
before you leave that's impressive
well sometimes you can get it pretty
cooked usually it's cooked but I guess
they gave you wrong one where do I even
throw this just in the toilet totally
okay look wait look wait look away Oh
God
alright it's all gone it's gone there's
no smelly dilute alright let's move on
good stuff that I was believing that was
good I was impressive god damn poor duck
yeah it was weird when you don't see it
cook too
and when you see it uncooked it made it
even worse ten times worse you're eating
the placenta everything yeah well I mean
it's a traditional food sure sure
I know y'all eat food we all eat animals
yeah are we live we're live
Brendon almost threw up that actually
ran out of his chair he was standing by
the door as though I were holding a
large
dude I just those eggs are here but I
feel it's also pretty [ __ ] up those
work that's a fetus in yeah I think chin
you're supposed to cook those before he
brought those people they're supposed to
be cooked yeah I was raw that was a raw
I feel bad I felt bad I felt a little
sad opening that egg that was the worst
possible oh I felt sad glad you felt
sick
I almost lost it's a sad and sick
episode by the way I'm on my last trip
Invisalign I'm done with this deal two
weeks let me see it see they're very
straight working well that's just hay it
down a notch but yeah that they work
dude let me see let me see straight on
well one two there's a little higher
than I still got the city skyline a
little bit but now they're not fighting
for position yeah I'll tell you what
wouldn't that woman was wearing the back
now this one's gonna be on the front he
almost came too far forward now yeah you
know what you don't wouldn't kill you
why didn't I oh my god yeah he looks
like a wooden floor on the bottom bro no
that's not true yeah teeth look like
Staples Center I answered that uh what
Kermit yeah chin that was yeah that
balloon sideways so bad I almost almost
threw up on the standing by the door
looking at me like you know how like um
like a deer looks at you like you know
huh at the corner of it I was not ready
for that
yeah I thought you know I was ready for
the bat Brendon literally was he was
standing sideways looking at me sideways
I get one hand on the doorknob is the
strangest thing waiting for me to be
done with this egg way to go chin you
hungry well I don't do well with that
stuff Vilas
soldier I'm a song surprised he still
got PTSD his hands are in his pocket
I need somewhere cold is keeping his
hand yeah I don't feel good he's all
hunched over and protective tell you
what if you want to act so Onegin with
this [ __ ] butcher knife people like
you the [ __ ] throws dead fetus it's like
that's
syncs hefty - yes Easter happy Easter
happy Easter giant eggs for everybody's
your price and don't crack them open
I'd be chocolate in man don't crack them
open because we'll be having a good time
with baby Jesus day - real sad time
there's an actual chicken in here with
the eyes and a beak and he smiles mm-hmm
when you open its me covered in blood
yeah my daughter's itself
self-prescribed
vegetarian at 10 years old drives me
crazy chilean eggs though what else all
right what do you got all right you want
me to start first a cat we both got some
stuff go ahead you guys like oh you guys
pick all right I'll go first
just kidding here's cats okay so there
has been a strawberry recall in
Australia because a specific brand
called Australia's choice has a batch of
strawberries that have needles in them a
man was actually rushed to the hospital
because I guess he swallowed a
strawberry whole without really chewing
and he swallowed the needle and so a
bunch of their strawberries have been
recalled it actually just reached New
Zealand this week and yet some psycho is
trying to sabotage the company and also
getting off on wait wait horns actual
syringe needles no like almost like so
sewing needles yeah so someone's
sticking them in the strawberries and
they're not quite sure who's doing it
they think it's probably from somewhere
between the distributor to the people
who send it to the grocery stores with
me and a boy a teenage boy was actually
connected to this but they're thinking
that he's a copycat because there's no
way that he could have had access to the
main supply of strawberries to do so
much damage so right now there's a lot
of sociopath people get off on doing
[ __ ] yeah it's like that and watching
the effect that is a classic so that's a
classic sociopath right [ __ ] it on loser
well it's just the things and then know
that my friend who's a lawyer right
represents a kid over and over again who
starts fires dresses up like a fireman
and directs traffic around the fire
nowwhat enjoys a person that's in charge
watching things burn and then being a
fireman and directing beings so they go
that guy's not a fireman my friend has
had defendant 11 times and I was like
he's associated associated I don't like
the dumbass up because he's a kid he's
been he goes to juvie and he comes out
he goes to an analysis but now he's an
adult and he will still does it will
spend his life in jail yeah yeah there
you go
this guy's a loser punch needles and
strawberries yeah what else you got
I'm not eating strawberries no no so
there's a controversy about Milly Bobby
Brown and Drake texting each other on
the red carpet at the Emmys
during an interview Milly Bobby Brown
talked about her friendship with Drake
and so that they texted each other the
interviewers asked what they text each
other about okay she says that they
texts about boys she continued to say
that their last text message was Drake
saying I miss you and her saying I miss
you too and a lot of people don't feel
right about that but what better hold on
what were the conversation was the boy I
miss using my big deal like kids to be
friends she obviously looks up to Drake
he's way older saying I missed you I say
that to people all the time and he's
probably giving her advice about boys in
school like stay away from this there
are a dad but it'd be interesting to see
what we're so crazy now that we're
looking into the stuff eyes it's whether
it's appropriate for Drake to give
relationship advice the teenage girl
[ __ ] off of court yeah there's no
problem with it no after senator dick
bakes are flirting yeah that'd be weird
people are speculating that he's
grooming her because he was recently
linked to model named Bella Harris have
you ever seen have you ever seen Bella
yeah but he also there was a picture of
them together when she was 16 yeah okay
two years ago so that's why people would
see you did say I missed you so much
because like I miss you more so there is
this oh she said we take each other day
he was like I missed you so much
all right well hey hello weird okay we
got some give him the benefits the
hottest women on the plan have you seen
his girlfriend have you ever seen his
girlfriend their eight-year-old that
model Belle Harrison
dude
no I'm saying Oh Brian Oh Brian get your
dick out
thank you Paul how old is she she's 18
just recently turned 18 yeah you gotta
go to Instagram check out that I asked
chin yeah should be attractive 18 year
old term yeah that's legal brother
that's legal
now go and scroll down for me might
already looked at some of these chicken
keep going there's one keep going she's
in a big it there you go
bikini far left she's got a problem with
that she's out sir I love you more I
would I would say I hope everything's
going well is if there's any advice I
can offer you I would say hey I want you
I want you to be able here with all the
comments your ass is defined oh do you
see that that that spider-man video I
posted right yeah the little kid yeah
now what do you think was it go go to it
for a second just look you'd have to put
it on just look at my look what I'm
doing for a second then I'm gonna ask
you a question
so right there just look at that picture
what do you think was the 90% what do
you think 90% of all the comments were
yeah but I never look at comments but I
know you're grabbing them nope um 9/10
of the comments were about how how
amazing my squat was and how I can stay
in that squat and how flexible my ankles
are I was like what
that's all anybody had to tell you you
have a gay fan base yeah
what's with my heavy eyelids there we
got to get we gotta get the old eyes
tucked up no no it looks weird
pronounced I'm a hot chick you made it
about Union squad we can do that well I
was gonna say she's got wonderful curls
in her hair
interesting yeah it's true you have that
asian squat that's the problem
I grew up in Asia yeah you go
interesting yeah um I don't know we
segue from this back to Harris yeah
she's hot she's a she's delicious yeah
but um Drake's an I missed you so much
little aggressive photograph that's all
weird I
we'll admit that it gives me I kind of
went man let's I meant well but you know
what the brakes of ten I'm giving him
the benefit
oh no he's not hooking up with a 14 year
old no came out on Instagram afterwards
after this whole thing blew blow up she
came out and made a point to say that
the everybody else is making a big deal
out of nothing that they're just friends
and like mutual fans of each other cuz
yeah that's all it is
yeah Drake is a big fan of stranger
things for sure that's it but let's not
text I love you or miss you so much
still fourteen-year-old he's smarter now
you bright anything he was even get out
heathyr hey Millie Bobby vanilla brown
314 don't [ __ ] tell the text between
you and Drake Millie Bobby Brown milli
vanilli Bobby vanilla brown yeah she's a
rapper right musician I know she is I
also thought she does she raps I believe
she does Oh an interview she had Jimmy
Kimmel she did a little she's famous for
stranger things though she's from
England yes yes does an axiom yeah hmm
she also hooked up with Drake so what
else you got Jeff rumors oh so what else
you got Kat a viewer actually tagged you
and the fighter and the kid account in
this and want to get your opinion on
painting your lawn cuz I Milani my lawn
is looking freshest [ __ ] right now whoa
that was all brown and they just painted
[ __ ] that I mean do you take P
DS - I mean this is Josh to pay as well
you know let me see the finished product
holy [ __ ] do you know what I have areas
though that are tough to turn I have a
Brown splotch right down the front of my
gate I would just loved it Wow you know
what I'd rather people do that then
leave their [ __ ] Brown like if you're
not gonna do it at least paint it so it
looks nice wow how much is that also
because of almonds there's a water
drought in California one of the reasons
why not just spray paint it baby
yeah now I'm a guy who likes a nice
Greenlawn fresh-cut every day every week
I should say you do I just want to hear
my lawn I'm [ __ ] all over it and
ficuses yeah I know
but it's safe for children safe for pets
I'll tell you if you have a shitty lawn
man two to three months until it grows
out kind of like died here they won't
how much that is it's kind of cool
actually it works whatever they wrong we
have a really shitty lon
Wow looks really good I mean game
changer game changer for it makes the
neighborhood I'm a purist if you're
gonna do that you might as well [ __ ]
take all the storage you want in sports
so to each its own though I'm not gonna
hate on it there you go else you got
so bricks of marijuana have been washing
up ashore on Florida beaches due to the
hurricane Wow
so far they found a hundred pounds on
the beach and that doesn't include the
bricks that were stolen from people on
the beach Jesus Christ and it's just
from people trying to sneak it in and
then they probably get [ __ ] up or yeah
people are speculating right now that
it's probably a shipment gone wrong
because of the weather and the hurricane
going on right now and so it's washing
up on beaches they found a hundred
pounds so far is continually tell you
what else they found the Everglades
scientists found anacondas oh sure don't
want no Sun I found something else
Brendon scientists found three in fact
bull sharks tiger sharks saltwater
crocodiles no crocodiles what Nile
crocodiles it up in there where the
African crocodile
they found it there I found three of
them large ones oh yeah there's a
mystery to why they're there but they
think that exotic pets exotic pet trade
when they get unmanageable the guy goes
here you go I'll just drop you in the
canal now you got yourself some Nile
cross and they thrive over there okay
look at these little [ __ ] croc they
find humans delicious human being oh
they're a real problem are a [ __ ]
food source so bring up 300-mile ring up
now crocodiles and
Florida oh yeah is it Florida yeah
they're coming for ya they're coming for
you yeah well Newsweek says no need to
panic look at those things the thing
that's a lil bit corny to new research
published in the journal of
Herpetological conservation in biology
DNA analysis taken from three animals
captured between 2009 and 2014 confirmed
they were true Nile crocodiles that's a
concern these animals can get big
growing up to 20 feet long and weighing
as much as a small car and they're not
picky eaters they're blamed for about
200 human deaths a year as Florida
herpetologist Kenneth Crisco told the AP
they didn't swim from Africa but we
really don't know how they got into the
wild this is easier to ferret figure out
like DJ Khalid or something [ __ ]
bought one correct was like this thing's
way too big for my [ __ ] crib yeah put
it into the river those things thrive
and [ __ ] up all the [ __ ] American gay
rice and then you got problems so that's
right that's right this goes down here
be dragons here be dragon you know what
I can't get out of my head and Brian you
probably haven't heard it but I want you
to hear it
yeah the new Kanye with little pomp song
he hosted the porn Awards you know that
porno behind me when he released this
song yeah I want to hear and how about
Connie goes on Jimmy Kimmel and he goes
watch come on the scientists because I
love porno cuz I don't get why more
people are honest about it cause I watch
the show yeah I watched a ton of porno
hmm you don't heard this song you ever
heard Chen I've I've heard it it's so
short so what is this my ad my ad
blocker witness quacking so that's why
they're doing this turn this [ __ ] up you
finally catch your song we will have to
edit this out but I find me here I mean
Brian can [ __ ] turn that [ __ ] up chin
you tell me a more catchy song now the
lurch a little harsh
I love to see these out these Albert's
are held on a rule there how funny is
Kanye right here I feel like it's the
catchiest song Kansas listen to this
she might for you old man
a little bit I can't take my eyes off it
let me good that was it Wow that's it
who's that lady
man no idea was doing some all ye that
was so interesting can I tell you what I
appreciate about that Kanye West does
not care whether you like him or not
didn't give a [ __ ] he's just doing
something kind of outrageous there's
some dead [ __ ] right now
yeah man well it's true I like how he
was on Jimmy Kimmel though you bring it
was Jimmy Kimmel interview they go so
your time out poor new the [ __ ] don't
watch porn cuz everyone that we act like
with no one's watching it he's all watch
a shitload of it I thought of chin up at
the Times oh wait you're such a [ __ ]
ho I love it we have to watch the ad
real quick Todd what are these hats [ __ ]
my grad blocker just crashed and they
catch you too I'm down Gina banner I
feel like we could get those costumes do
our own are they yeah
we're too late very cute climbin on your
head do you dress them do you pick their
outfits mm-hmm you do is that fun for
you mm-hmm do you design outfits for
that mm-hmm do they love that I mean did
they understand that process so you draw
something and then it becomes their
clothes yeah my daughter went to a
fashion camp for five days a couple
weeks ago and I visited her visited her
and we put together we put the thread
through the sewing machine and it really
brought me to tears to think about the
15 years that I've been working on
apparel and for my friend Virgil to be
the head of Louis Vuitton and for me to
have this you know 1.8 billion dollar
company out of uh you know a thread
going through and she my daughter asked
me daddy do you have a sewing machine
sewing machine like this at your office
and I've brought her to my office and
she did a bunch of sketches and um my
hair pattern cutter made her dresses
right there real for her so she loves
coming to the office and doing sketches
boy that's so much more fun than my
dad's office one of the songs on your
album
is is about it you're in the song and
correct me if I have any of this wrong
you're imagining your daughter as an
adult dating and men looking at her mhm
and you're very very worked up about
this prematurely some might say do you
think about that you think that far
ahead
oh I think lifetimes and lifetimes ahead
and that and you actually are imagining
like guys the objectifying
do you feel like your attitude towards
women has changed since having daughters
no I still look at porn hub and
[Applause]
these holidays
what kind of stuff do you look at what
categories lacked is my favorite black
like this good what's the point of being
Kanye West if you can't let's break down
black and white obviously oh yeah I love
how it's mirroring your own self your
own situate my own reality Yeah right
it's like doubly master painting in a
way if you think about if you ever seen
the influence he's had on like the top
designers it's insane like Don see these
are Don C kicks is Chicago guy he made
these these hats and he'd put leather
bills on them and you could get him at
gas station Chicago and so like a lot of
like the the the kids and like the
younger crowd would wear and then Don C
gave one to Kanye and Kanye will ruin
like like seat like floor on the court
or just like sitting down a game and
then those [ __ ] things went crazy not
Don C's like one of the biggest fashion
guys in the game Virgil who's referring
to Virgil who's the head of who's the
head of Louis Vuitton now was his head
designer did all his merch fear of God
like his his hands in [ __ ] fashion is
insane the way he influences it and then
he dresses Kim so you know Kim sets the
fashion trend for women Kim and Kylie he
dresses all them he does it's insane
yeah there's right there Doxey and his
hat crazy right yeah that's all the
[ __ ] trend yep what else you get you
some quick ones here so the Elan musk
his first volunteer to go into space to
go around the moon is a Japanese
billionaire and they plan the schedule
is 2023 so super super successful
Japanese billionaire is gonna go up
there with six to eight other artists
like musicians artists a lot of stuff
because he wants them to all go together
so they be get inspired
what they see come back and contribute
to the to the world after smart that's
cool it takes 5 days 5 days 5 days to go
there and back yep that's not bad that's
not better off hold up 5 days to get
there they're gonna orbit around all
trip and then head back well the whole
trip whole trips how many days does it
take to get to the moon
I guess that's two and a half days a
what I don't want to be on that first
run no I don't know I'm not doing that
no thank you no send some brilliant
minds up there let me know how it is I
think you get what if they all came back
alive I think you get the earth is flat
you can show that underneath the Earth's
moon's gravity pulls you around or
something like that no idea something
like that of course some billionaires
can take him in his home he's up there
in [ __ ] what do we think about it you
have a you're a billionaire you have all
this money your life is great and
there's no guarantee you're coming back
they don't but he's woman do it he feels
like it's worth it's worth trust me lon
musk mm-hmm I wouldn't go on that
journey for if they offer me a free
ticket I would not do it I'd be
terrified all right but I also have no
interest in going around the moon for
five days you should look out the window
a lot know this you know what that moons
gonna be you're still four days and then
the first initial viewing like oh [ __ ]
that's the moon yeah it looks like
Danakil to the pictures I saw an
elementary you are really close to it
yeah but then after the initial shock
double your what you're looking at then
I think it's over right I don't know
then you'd look at the other asteroids
and stuff like that right I mean I don't
know well that's a stupid picture that's
the day of their announcement I think
it's cool I think it's quiet I want no
part of that same it's gonna be cool
though take some sweet pictures of the
new iPhones you won't get the new iPhone
nah I need go get it man they're sold
out everywhere nope wrong girl I found a
place
ooh what else you got a guy found
there's a new iPhone yeah well it's good
access and all that
this one this Denver Colorado the
Colorado Buffaloes do you know that team
get the [ __ ] back yeah I played for my
ship the buffman
do I know that team chips the mascot so
that this mascot tried to fire a t-shirt
you know t-shirt cannons yeah it
malfunctioned and instead of shooting
the t-shirt out it blew up in on his
junk wait why are they shooting out of
his junk what I mean the word they were
like shooting it through his legs I'm
sure when you hold it it's like position
store it somewhere near your pelvis so
you can see this it it looks pretty bad
too oh and he was out he got knocked
down
yeah not goood I was really bad he's
knocked him out chin well you knocked
him down because there's so much pain
but they got carried on field
[Applause]
okay well Jew he's kicking his legs you
know how bad that would hurt
oh my gun she's mean you never been
kicked Annette's little own shot in the
na with a cannon like that dude I bet
that hurt so bad
that's all ball is it it's from back
there bro it hit that grandfather clock
backside high [ __ ] had to walk a pole
I was eight feet up and you fall into
cushion you know at that that parkour
gym and I I'm walking I it's so scary I
don't know why and it's like you're just
gonna fall in the cushions but you're
eight feet high so you have to walk this
high road I make it across somehow I
come running across the next time about
a fall I grab on to the the metal bar
and swing and and catch my underarms and
my pokémon and I feel myself up I didn't
say anything I was like good I hit the
inside of me my [ __ ] and my armpit
everything I almost I almost took all a
major spill but did you end the night
nope I'll just hurt myself oh that
[ __ ] hurt man I thought about how bad
it would have been god oh well good
thing chips okay I don't like action
still haven't been in the nuts
not yet alright not kicked not kicked in
the nuts you said no oh you girls okay
yeah
what else yet in this here okay so
there's a McDonald's restaurant in Texas
and these two guys are that are Asian
they looked around all the different
posters and there was no Asian people as
other deafness other ethnicities news
all the way people ethnicities there's
all white or black people or Mexican
Latin okay with no Asian no agency
that's great
so they made this poster they spent a
lot of money to do this and they
secretly hung it up inside the
McDonald's by buying some like
McDonald's outfit outfits from Goodwill
putting them on snuck it in there and it
wasn't noticed for 51 days until they
posted it on Twitter and then it got you
know what viral do you know what they
call that that's called criticizing by
creating that would be that would be
correct
Michelangelo and McDonald's gave them
$25,000 for it yeah so here's what
they're doing they're gonna renovate
this place anyways so this good the
posters gonna go down but they're having
these two guys come in for an
advertisement they're paying them 25 G's
that's correct and they made it onto
freakin Ellen Show no I love that it's a
long it's a long clip but she was
talking about how it brilliant it was
nothing cool man besides by creating
good for them it's awesome that's cool
and they were inspired by that movie
crazy rotation stead of criticizing my
shame have you seen it create no you
didn't way we've seen it what's that I
haven't gone to the movies in forever
what movie I wanna watch Asian arms I
feel like a bad Asian for now yeah yeah
they're bad Asian groundbreaker true
yeah people say it's amazing I heard
it's opening doors which I didn't I
didn't realize it would really do what
its opening doors for Asians you know
why entertainment if I go you can make a
movie with all Asians and it makes a
fortune to hit what happened there's a
girl we know that works here who heard
scripts getting looked at because of the
movie nice Sarah oh really yeah Oh dope
yeah cool cool what else you get what
else do I have here
oh yeah so colin kaepernick his ad
actually generated six billion dollars
more for Nike even with all the
controversy not surprising to me
generate six billion in what way it says
market value so they're they're worth
has gone up more six but it's gone up
but it was already like five and a half
bill
it was worth like five and half that
said that's a that's a marketing scheme
that's a little bit of uh that's
financing the measure right yeah but
they're worth five something billion of
before Kapernick well he said it's sick
it added six point six billion
oh that's not true oh I see what they're
saying they're saying because the stock
went up so much how about people were
like I'm burning my Nikes and then post
them feather Nikes on fire yeah the
Kaepernick [ __ ] and people were pissed
off because you could have give them to
homeless people or whatever it is no
sense interesting damn six billion more
I wonder why do we know how much
Kaepernick they paid how much did they
give that man for that deal we have no
idea no they shouldn't have it up really
because he should be negotiating more
now but it's too late how much you think
he they gave them B now probably few mil
for sure
maybe he might have a revenue share of
some kind I don't know but he doesn't
have like a signature
well they've learned sometimes in stock
22 million [ __ ] Wow they pay you in
stock I was in 2016 that's when he's
playing all the ball will he play again
run no just because he's a thing he
wasn't very good yeah he's a boozer wait
what he's doing now he's way more famous
for he was good for a few years in the
NFL and once they figured out the game
plan he just wasn't that good so you
have this guy who's way more famous
outside the field and he was in the
field he wasn't that good to begin with
he had a few good years but when when
when then I kind of figured him out yeah
and then he didn't we wasn't that good
so I mean he should be in the NFL but is
it would it be a starter no he but he
should be on a team but he won't be
contributing I don't think he's better
than any of the starters the 32 starters
they have now do you think that with
quarterbacks like for with running backs
who lasts a lot shorter than they used
to do you think it's because defenses
are figuring out where they're where
their liabilities are so you'll see
quarterbacks
more playing two years like rg3 then
they figure I'm out for some in the
pocket to pay at pass and stuff
June you're gonna have is that gonna be
more of a complicated question and I
could get him cuz it all depends you get
in trouble well it does it I think I
know
quarterbacks last a long time especially
if you have a franchise quarterback
right there's certain style sometimes a
certain very athletic in college can
take shortcuts that you don't get a
reserve Fisher Rose you know yeah yeah
the certain styles that the NFL Kim yeah
thank you force you to pass and beat
back feels and you haven't done that but
in me to finally get quarterbacks
Hardman yeah it's freakin hard yeah I
would have to get Jen I think that's all
the big ones oh this guy you know the
guy that sent out 3d printing yeah I
glanced for guns yeah he's in Taiwan
they found them yeah he was he was a
fugitive they found out that he was on a
website sugar daddy something okay ended
up meeting a girl the girl happened to
be according allegedly 16 years old but
on the website she said she was older
that could have been had that could have
had sex with her in her hotel room
yeah for 500 bucks and then found out
after she was 16 that's the thing we
don't know yet yeah well fellas Alliance
says she's 18 or 21 yeah really yeah
you're still in a world of trouble and
have her on videotape him and her
walking into the motel or hotel yeah but
he fled to Taiwan at the time oh well
something's up then they look then they
got him back now alright yeah see I
would say if they capped rooms I called
up she told me she was [ __ ] 21 she
showed me a fake ID she was 21
we had consensual sex there's no problem
here but when they go hey she was 16 and
he fleet fled to [ __ ] Taiwan
something's up that'll all come out in
the trial yeah that's scary that's going
to trial yeah why would you plead a
[ __ ] Taiwan yeah
there's also conspiracy people saying
that you know the government wants to
shut him down so they found a way to get
him that way
maybe maybe why don't we talk number 60
meet so don't do we think the the
government logged him on a sugar daddy
calm
what was the girl
sugar-daddy meet com2 daddy even bragged
himself being like a big deal on that
that yeah what about Jeb Bill Cosby he's
being sentenced alright but we don't
know if it outright yeah yeah he's
[ __ ]
yeah there's like 1,000 women well this
is all resting on one case because the
others type of statutes moment this old
school he's so old 81 years old and
blind his one eyes what a fall from
grace yeah nothing you won't end this on
a positive note how about Tiger Woods oh
he's back baby backed off his back
yep shout out to Tiger Woods yep that it
chin that's it shout to Tiger would
shout out to balut eggs you're gonna be
in Seattle this LP broke my day Saturday
son go see Brendon Bellevue parlor live
great room then after then I'm in a
wiseguys Utah in October wise guys
October don't you get them I might come
and open for you let's do a brother
Perry brother wiseguys that it dude
sinus hot buddy this is the fun kid
we're out